hi everyone this is Jerry and this is
another live blitz game I just put a
couple seeks out for a five minute game
in a three minute game for players 2000
or greater ok rubs II dubsy 2166 I've
played this guy quite a few times
already I'm gonna play the the French
defense actually whenever the youtubers
has been commenting that they want to
see the French defense so let's go with
this
I believe the youtubers name was virtual
wall virus here we go so on a three why
was intending I'm playing pawn to b4 to
put a question to this pawn right away
um do I take yeah I'm gonna take first
if he recaptures like this I'm gonna
play bishop here see my bishop did the
intention I have is just to get rid of
my light square bishop my light square
bishop is considered to be my bad bishop
in comparison to my dark square bishop I
want to have my pawns on light squares
since I have just one dark dark square
bishop remaining or just one bishop
remaining in it's on a dark square so
I'm happy that I achieved that much I
have to play here so that my bishop can
now cover against Knight d6 check I'll
probably castle I'm gonna play this move
because I don't want to let Bishop e7 be
met with Bishop here I don't want to
allow this bishop exchange I want to
hang on to this guy
he's gonna serve a a good purpose in
watching over this hole on d6 what
happened there okay I just backed up
accidentally so I'll play Knight here
get my rook here
I went exchange off this knight he's
going he's pretty much a pest what's
going on with this is this just a
blunder Wow well that is a
that's that was a quick game yeah what
sound let's see if he'll do a rematch
maybe we'll get another one in there oh
no he's not logged in I guess he had his
fill for right now but yeah that was
just a blunder let's just go back so the
French defense this is very typical when
these pawns are staggered in this manner
black is looking to definitely strike at
the bait the tail of the pawn chain with
this move pawn to c5 and as sometime in
some variations the French defense will
sleep on to f6 striking at the head of
the pawn chain that that often needs
some more care to it to strike at the
head of a pawn chain but it's almost
always the case that you you strike at
the tail of the upon chain so just clean
development the reason I didn't this is
a very typical move but I played my
queen up because I want to do this
bishop maneuver to exchange off my bad
bishop it's often the case in the French
defense that this Bishop right here is
the bad Bishop so I was just trying to
get rid of him for whites good bishop so
night out Bishop d7 pawn here preparing
pawn to b4 where it would put a question
to this pawn and I would have to do
something either capture and one or two
directions and I just didn't want to
have to meet that so that's what
prompted this upon the a5 move on to b3
and if I play Bishop here right now I
believe he could play pawn push so
that's why I took on d4 first take take
and only now here so this trade is going
to occur so Bishop takes Queen takes
Knight out with tempo so just play back
to d7 I do have to worry of this square
as a result of this pawn to e5 moved
this b6 where as a whole so I mean if
you played Knight here I'd have to worry
about the knight hopping down to this
square but that wasn't the case instead
he played Queen Queen d3 Knight here I'm
just trying to develop my king side
first so that's why I did these two
moves back-to-back Knight here getting
ready to hop into the whole night again
move to c6 castle and I believe this is
a very important move right here Pandey
six I played Bishop e7 again this Bishop
could come here in exchange itself off I
don't want to allow this exchange this
is considered a bad Bishop as a result
of this these pawns being on dark
squares so he's going to be responsible
for this d6 square so upon to h6 Bishop
out Bishop e7 rook on F 2 c1 Castle and
then rook c2 preparing to just double
Knight to a six and I guess I don't know
I guess he thought that my rook was the
only protector of this pawn right here
but Bishop takes and then I would just
reply Knight take so that was just a
very quick blunder made by rub seed of Z
but he's somebody who has beaten me many
times before we kind of go back and
forth but he's a definitely good player
just I guess had a bad game rating and
commenting has always are appreciated
thanks so much bye